le Mexique dans l'objectif documentaire
signé par Benjamin Lalande un voyage
vous venez de le voir sans concession au
cœur du Mexique d'aujourd'hui à travers
le regard la parole et le travail de ces
photographes le Mexique miné par la
criminalité et les inégalités et
culturellement tiraillé entre l'Amérique
du Sud et les États-Unis quels sont les
enjeux qui attendent désormais le pays
nous allons en débattre maintenant avec
les invités qui sont présents sur ce
plateau de débat doc aujourd'hui Elodie
Borda Chauvin pour commencer bienvenue à
vous vous êtes sociologue spécialiste
des politiques culturelles en Amérique
latine et en Europe et auteur entre
autres de cet ouvrage les politiques
culturelles en Argentine et au Mexique
publiées chez L'Harmattan vous étiez il
y a pas si longtemps au Mexique les plus
précisément dans sa capitale Mexico nous
allons donc avoir des nouvelles toutes
fraîches du pays qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui on va le faire avec vous
aussi Thierry Noel bienvenue vous êtes
des chercheurs spécialistes des
questions politiques diplomatiques et de
sécurité en Amérique latine et auteur de
la guerre des cartels 30 ans de trafic
de drogue au Mexique c'est un ouvrage
qui est disponible chez vendémières on
va commencer si vous le voulez bien par
une carte bien entendu pour situer le
Mexique entre vous le voyez le Golf du
Mexique et l'océan Pacifique avec
notamment cette très longue frontière au
nord
3200 km avec les États-Unis dont il est
beaucoup question dans le documentaire
et que nous venons de voir et pourquoi
nous irons viendrons d'ailleurs ensemble
le pays compte quelques 129 millions
d'habitants c'est une république
fédérale qui compte 32 États dont
mexicaux la capitale avec ses 23
millions d'habitants et qui bénéficient
d'un statut spécial d'ailleurs Mexico
premier sujet il apparaît il est
omniprésent dans ce documentaire que
nous venons de voir c'est la criminalité
au Mexique avec cette fameuse guerre des
cartels c'est l'objet de votre livre ou
encore appelé la guerre de la drogue en
15 ans plus de 350
000 assassinats ont eu lieu au Mexique
plus d'une centaine de milliers de
disparition également l'an dernier on a
dénombré 33 300 assassinats c'est 91
assassinats par jour au Mexique je
répète ce chiffre 91 assassinat par jour
au Mexique nous parlons avec ce pays du
deuxième pays le plus meurtrier au monde
première question comment en est-on
arrivé là avec cette fameuse guerre des
cartes
c'est une question complexe il y a
sûrement pas une seule réponse c'est un
cocktail d'éléments j'ai un cocktail
malheureusement explosif
le documentaire ou en très très bien il
y a cette frontière cette frontière avec
les États-Unis plus grand marché de la
drogue qui fait du Mexique à la fois un
producteur une zone de passage de
quantité de drogue venue parfois plus au
sud de depuis la Colombie par exemple en
passant par l'Amérique centrale donc
l'apparition de gigantesques cartel qui
se dédie au trafic mais aussi à se
battre entre eux pour essayer de
contrôler ce marché extraordinaire ce
marché multimilliardaire tout ceci gère
une violence
effarante dans le pays que ce soit des
guerres déclenchées par les autorités
avec une militarisation et de la lutte
contre le trafic ou encore une fois de
ces conflits entre cartels eux-mêmes
depuis les plus grandes organisations
depuis les plus petites conflits à
l'échelle nationale conflit à l'échelle
locale il y avait un nombre de victimes
encore une fois tout à fait effarant on
parle des
glucides il faut aussi parler des
disparitions qui s'élèvent à plusieurs
dizaines de milliers c'est une situation
évidemment avec les femmes notamment qui
sont particulièrement concernés j'ai
oublié de citer un chiffre un 1200
agressions de femmes par jour au Mexique
avec des enlèvements qui ont fait
l'objet d'ailleurs du travail d'une des
photographes qu'on a vu dans ce film
pour bien comprendre le Mexique était un
producteur de drogue ou simplement un
lieu de passage entre la Colombie avec
la cocaïne pour commencer vers les
États-Unis et c'était un lieu de
distribution de drogue vers les
États-Unis où c'était d'emblée un
producteur de drogue les deux en fait
sur place ont produit de la marijuana
qui traditionnellement par vers les vers
les États-Unis c'est rajouter ensuite il
y a eu c'est rajouté l'opium ramener
d'Asie et qui est devenu un des points
forts du trafic mexicain ensuite la
cocaïne notamment depuis la Colombie et
enfin on a une dernière couche la plus
récente peut-être qui sont toutes les
drogues de synthèse
et autres là aussi avec des produits
ramenés souvent d'Asie d'Inde de Chine
transformer sur place et amener aux
États-Unis dont on sait qu'ils sont en
train de créer une épidémie d'overdose
absolument absolument terrible alors
qu'est-ce que ça provoque cette guerre
des cartels au niveau politique au
niveau de la gestion du pays j'imagine
qu'on a tenté des choses du coup du côté
des pouvoirs publics le constat est là
malgré tout est-ce qu'on peut parler des
chèques aujourd'hui
alors si je peux me permettre de
compléter les travaux de mon collègue
on a eu le déclenchement d'une dite
guère contre la narcotrafic par un
ancien président felipecalleron en 2007
et à partir de là on a quand même une
explosion de la violence c'est-à-dire
qu'on a une gestion publique de cette
criminalité
à très grande échelle avec beaucoup de
moyens une très grande puissance
qui est un échec mais qui a un échec
depuis plusieurs mandats du coup donc on
a eu des politiques des parties de
droite plus traditionnelles avec ce
président Calderon puis ensuite avec le
parti qui restait très longtemps au
pouvoir qui a vraiment structuré la vie
politique et sociale du Mexique le prix
le parti de la Révolution
institutionnalisée
du pouvoir pendant
plus de 70 ans
de la Révolution jusqu'en 2000 puis les
revenus au pouvoir avec Enrique
penianetto juste avant le président qui
a été élu et qui est toujours au pouvoir
presque depuis 4 ans Andres manuel Lopez
sorado du coup ce président de gauche
a voulu mener une politique différente
l'un de ces arguments de campagne était
pas de balle mais des câlins balaze noir
mais on voit que finalement c'est une
politique différente qui a été qui a été
menée et l'une des plus grandes
critiques qu'on en pose à ce
gouvernement tout parti confondu c'est
la militarisation des questions de
sécurité donc la militarisation de
d'une branche de se charger du problème
c'est ça mais sans passer directement
par l'armée c'est à dire que il avait
créé
une police spécifique pour ces questions
là qui devaient être indépendante qui
était jusqu'à il y a peu sous le
contrôle du ministère de la Sécurité
publique et la très récemment il y a une
loi qui est passée qui a été approuvée
par le Sénat visant à permettre à ce que
ce cette police spécifique passe sous
contrôle derrière l'armée alors il y
avait déjà beaucoup de militaires qu'il
intégrait et on voit des des
organisations comme Amnesty
International qui dénonce le fait que
depuis que l'armée a beaucoup plus un
rôle beaucoup plus important dans cette
gestion de enfin si on peut appeler ça
une gestion de la crise avec le
narcotrafic et les cartel on a beaucoup
plus de cas de violation des droits
humains
avec des groupes à la fois militaires et
para militaires par exemple le tia passe
dans les communautés s'apatistes
autonome
on a beaucoup de dénonciation d'exaction
remise par par les militaires pour bien
évaluer le poids de la drogue et du
narcotrafic dans dans ce pays j'ai pu
lire que 6 états sur 32 concentre 50%
des victimes domicile est-ce que ces
états sont des narco-états à l'intérieur
même du Mexique et ce que le Mexique
lui-même n'est pas en train de devenir
un arco-état puisque la drogue
représenterait jusqu'à 9% du PIB du pays
aujourd'hui alors l'appellation narco
est en pour la discuter elle est
peut-être un peu forte parce qu'elle
supposerait une implication je dirais
franchi direct de l'État et de toutes
les institutions d'État dans le
narcotrafic c'est pas le cas même si
bien évidemment la corruption est au
profit de arcotrafic ou du fait du
narcotrafic et très malheureusement
répandu à ce qu'on appelle les trois les
trois niveaux de l'État mexicain au
niveau municipal au niveau des États et
au niveau fédéral on trouve des cas
comme ça de la parler malgré le scandale
qui ont pu émerger régulièrement depuis
plusieurs décennies leur co-état je
pense qu'il faut peut-être rester là
après il est tout à fait clair que des
zones entières du territoire sont hors
de contrôle de
surtout les autres de transit ou de
production drogue
ou des ponts bien sûr des habitants et
qui en sont les premières victimes et il
est évident comme le il y a toutes les
institutions qui seront envoyées au
contact de ces trafiquants dans la lutte
dont on le trafic sont malheureusement
on peut bien le dire régulièrement
contaminés par par ce trafic là la
référence effectivement la cette fameuse
garde nationale on avait déjà des
acteurs policiers ou des acteurs
militaires qui étaient engagés quand on
Arte au trafic le président Manuel Lopez
a introduit cette garde nationale qui
était censée être une solution à tout
cela et qui elle-même maintenant se
retrouve impliqué donc quantité de
scandale le président actuel vous situez
tout à l'heure Enrique pena ni
qui était le président
juste avant celui qui officie
aujourd'hui depuis
2018 il est exilé aujourd'hui en Espagne
parce que il avait été mis en examen
dans son pays pour enrichissement
illiciter ce que c'est enrichissement
illicite était était justement lié à la
drogue à la guerre des cartels auquel on
fait référence
alors c'est pour montrer le degré si
vous voulez le corruption qui peut
exister peut-être au Mexique aujourd'hui
c'est un film que je recommande à nos
téléspectateurs et téléspectatrices qui
montrent assez bien à quel point le
narcotrafic peut toucher
de nombreux niveaux de la société
mexicaine mon collègue a sûrement vu il
s'agit d'Ali me fierno de Luis Strada
l'enfer et qui montre à quel point en
fait toute la société
est imprégnée de près ou de loin par
cette thématique là on a eu également le
cas de Garcia Luna qui était chargé de
lutter contre le
narcotrafic dont on avait entendu parler
en France suite à l'affaire de Florence
CACES d'ailleurs un documentaire a été
créé sur cette question en français
récemment lui il a été mis en examen il
a été jugé par les États-Unis pour
corruption donc justement Andress manuel
lopezobrador voulait marquer une
véritable rupture par rapport à des
anciens présidents à cette impunité à
cette corruption en
donnant des gages très très forts des
choses très symboliques rendre par
exemple au peuple mexicain la résidence
des présidents c'est comme si d'un seul
coup l'Élysée devenait un musée ouvert à
tous il a également baissé fortement son
salaire et refuse de prendre l'avion
présidentiel etc donc vraiment une
marque de rupture vis-à-vis de ça avec
cette idée que la lutte contre la
corruption était vraiment son cheval de
bataille et il a pris parfois des
décisions un petit peu controversées et
et qui ont eu des effets
pervers je pense c'est le fait de
d'arrêter tout de subventions aux
associations en disant il y avait
beaucoup trop de corruption notamment au
sein de grandes associations il y avait
beaucoup trop de d'argent qui partaient
comme ça donc on va donner
principalement de l'argent aux pauvres
pour résoudre la problématique dont vous
parliez qui est celle des inégalités sur
les inégalités parce que écrit crayon
aussi dans ce pays je voulais juste avec
cette partie de la criminalité et le
degré de corruption dans dans la société
économique et politique mexicaine très
important alors autre chose que j'ai
noté la proportion des homicides par
armes à feu est passé de 15 % en 1997 à
70 % en 2021 et la faute à qui bien la
faute aux États-Unis parce que ces armes
proviennent des États-Unis le port
d'arme est autorisé aux États-Unis il ne
l'est pas au Mexique et toutes ces armes
viennent des États-Unis c'est-à-dire que
cette guerre des cartels est au bénéfice
des États-Unis quand on y regarde de
près c'est le cas
c'est un des points qui est opposé aux
États-Unis qui
exige du Mexique de contrôler
narcotrafic celui-ci à l'inverse
retourne notamment le l'actuel
administration autour de l'argument en
faisant remarquer effectivement que les
États-Unis eux sont fournisseurs d'armes
donc
nourrissent cette violence qui existe au
Mexique en disant qu'il y aurait 2,5
millions d'armes qui seraient arrivés
des États-Unis au Mexique pour alimenter
cette fameuse guerre c'est un marché
énorme et le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est qu'il y a en plus aucun contrôle
ou en tout cas extrêmement peu qui est
effectué côté américain et que les
arbres entrent avec immense simplicité
au Mexique nous risque de trafic
nourrissent toute forme de violence des
fois sur des cas extrêmement grave
d'ailleurs des massacres qui plus que
d'autres ont marqué l'opinion on a
retrouvé ses armes fournies par les
États-Unis et j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
états mexicains qui voulaient porter
plainte et qui ont cherché à porter
plainte contre les États-Unis
pour lutter contre ces exportations
d'armes au Mexique tout à fait il faut
dire en plus que en dehors de cette
vente semi légale effectuée à la
frontière avec une multiplication des
armurerie américaine le long de la
frontière donc on comprend bien qu'elle
soit destination du Mexique il faut
aussi dire qu'il y a eu des politiques
pour le moinsardeuses restons prudent
sur les termes de la part de l'État
américain lui-même qui a parfois
autorisé des trafics d'armes vers le
Mexique sous prétexte de suivre les
filières de trafic mais en fait on
nourrissant le réalimentant le trafic
sans aucun contrôle encore une fois
armes qui ensuite ont été très
documentée servie à des massacres
absolument atroces sur place donc oui la
critiquer légitime il y a un vrai
problème
alors c'est vrai que vous l'avez cité
tout à l'heure Philippe et Calderon qui
était lui aussi un ancien président du
Mexique et c'est lui qui finalement est
au cœur de cette guerre à partir de 2016
considérer que pour trouver
pour remonter les filières des
narcottafiquants il faut aller remonter
la filière des armes pour en revenir à
ce que nous nous disions tout à l'heure
il y a eu même un programme qui avait
mis en place s'il te plaît Fast and
Furious qui consistait à mettre des
traceurs dans les armes qui provenaient
des États-Unis pour mieux évidemment
tracer ses armes après du côté mexicain
ça aussi ça semble-t-il ça a été un
échec
oui et il avait identifié une des causes
peut-être de la de la hausse de la
criminalité dans son pays non peut-être
mais en tout cas effectivement c'est
politique ont été un échec total enfin
c'est vraiment à partir de son sexe et
que la situation devient complètement
ingérable je pense que comme le disait
mon collègue on a une crise
multifactorielle et justement vous êtes
aussi un spécialiste de la Colombie il y
a énormément de transfert de savoir de
transfert d'expérience et d'expertise
entre la Colombie et le Mexique en ce
moment pour essayer de trouver des
solutions différentes par exemple des
solutions venant des propres communautés
de des propres quartiers par exemple
vous disiez que j'étais au Mexique il y
a peu de temps je me suis rendue dans la
plus grande cité HLM d'Amérique latine
800 000 habitants qui est la lunida
d'habitationale donc c'est comme ça
qu'on appelle un HLM mais le rosalium et
donc
j'étais dans un centre culturel où on
m'expliquait que cette grande citation
HLM avait été très bien pensée pour qui
est tout un réseau de communication qui
permet d'aller à l'école d'aller acheter
son pain d'aller au supermarché en
passant par tout un tas de réseaux
souterrains de communication des ponts
etc et que du coup c'était devenu une
parfaite plateforme pour le trafic de
drogue et que en implantant ce centre
culturel à la place d'un ancien d'une
ancienne décharge
ils avaient cherché à attirer les
habitants de cette cité HLM pour venir
et bien se former autour de d'ateliers
culturel donc autour des costumes de
masques moi j'étais pendant les
célébrations de dire des muertos donc
que que vous avez vu et enfin que vous
avez vu en France il y a eu beaucoup
d'événements autour de ça et donc c'est
essayer de récupérer des petits kiosques
comme celui-ci qu'on voyait en photo
récupérer l'espace public ne plus le
laisser au trafic de drogue plus le
laisser à la délinquance mais se
réapproprier de ces espaces les
inégalités c'est le deuxième point fort
lorsqu'on on scrute un petit peu la
situation politique sociale de ce pays
en 2018 selon l'OCDE 48% de la
population vivait dans la pauvreté
1% des plus riches concentre 36% de la
richesse nationale
comment est-ce qu'on explique cette
inégalité frappante
du côté du Mexique on est sur un pays
totalement inégalitaire là aussi c'est
sûrement dur à expliquer c'est plus
généralement
aussi une particularité de la team
américaine même si le pas exclusif mais
c'est un très répandu en Amérique latine
particulièrement fort au Mexique avec on
l'a vu dans le documentaire des écarts
de richesse mais proprement hallucinant
entre des élites qui ont fait des
fortunes il y a d'immense fortune
mondiales et effectivement des
populations notamment des populations de
communauté indigènes je pense à lui
Guerrero dans mexicain dans lequel on
vit dans des conditions de pauvreté mais
absolument hallucinante bien évidemment
tout ça est un aussi nourri nourri la
violence dans dans de parler
il y a ces inégalités elles sont
extrêmement fortes effectivement on l'a
dit l'actuel président a promis et a été
élu aussi sur une promesse de réduction
de celle-ci le fait que c'est un
chantier de plus extraordinaire et qui
rencontre de multiples résistances de
tous les côtés et bien évidemment encore
une fois avec cette question du
narcotrafic qui lui soit disant devrait
agir comme un égalisateur il y a cette
promesse de richesse à travers le
narcotrafic mais qui dans la partie
qu'on sait très bien n'est qu'une
province de bourrée de violence pour
beaucoup de gens qui essaient de
s'enrichir à travers le trafic alors
vous l'avez dit cette pauvreté ces
inégalités notamment chez les jeunes
allez entre 16 ans et 25 ans qui
choisissent le camp des narcotrafiquants
plutôt que le travail légal ce qui
alimente évidemment cette guerre qui se
poursuit aujourd'hui au Mexique et c'est
vrai que le président en place à lui
chercher et vous l'avez commencé à le
dire tout à l'heure à inverser la
logique c'est à dire qu'il considère que
plutôt que la guerre il faut des câlins
et dans les c'était de redonner du
pouvoir d'achat et bien évidemment pour
commencer aux pauvres au Mexique est-ce
qu'il a
obtenu quelques points depuis le début
de sa présidence c'était en 2018 de ce
point de vue là et obtenu quelques
résultats il continue à avoir des taux
de popularité assez élevé après 4 ans de
mandat la base ce sont des mandats de 6
ans
il a il a été maire de Mexico pendant
longtemps avant d'être de président et
lorsqu'il était à la tête de la capitale
c'est le premier à avoir donné ce qu'on
appelle chez nous les retraites parce
qu'il faut savoir qu'au Mexique il y
avait pas de système de retraite on voit
des personnes de 80 ans qui sont encore
en train de travailler donc
vis-à-vis de ces populations les plus
pros on voit qu'il y a encore beaucoup
de soutien on parlait tout à l'heure des
communautés auto autochtones par exemple
dans le documentaire on voit très bien
cette zone de de glissement de tawantek
avec ses immenses éoliennes et juste à
côté à quelques kilomètres il y a des
communautés autochtones qui n'ont pas
d'électricité juste à côté de ces
éoliennes donc c'est pour moi une belle
illustration de cette société
profondément inégalitaire et comme le
disait monsieur Noël c'est pas du tout
une particularité du Mexique à la
Rouquier appelle l'Amérique latine le
continent des inégalités je pense que là
c'est véritablement un héritage de la
colonisation
tous lu dans notre jeunesse Eduardo
Galiano avec ses veines ouvertes de
l'Amérique latine je pense qu'il y a
encore des phénomènes de
néo-colonialisme d'impérialisme on le
voit ces immenses champ d'éoliennes qui
sont arrivés avec des compagnies souvent
étrangères et qui ne donne pas des
électricité aux communautés qui sont une
dizaine de kilomètres donc alors il y a
effectivement des succès de cette
politique après il y a énormément de
critiques beaucoup de
alors de toutes les de tous les bords
politiques c'est-à-dire autant de la
droite les anciens panistes qui qui sont
en campagne puisque les élections vont
avoir lieu en 2024 mais on a déjà des
candidats qui se sont déclarés bien sûr
l'opposition du prix mais aussi de la
gauche traditionnelle la gauche qui lui
en veut d'avoir le budget d'avoir
complètement réduit les budgets pour
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
les bourses les bourses de pour les
étudiants d'avoir également donné le
budget le plus bas à la culture depuis
des années alors que encore une fois
c'est un gouvernement de gauche on a
enfin un ministère de la Culture et on a
pourtant vraiment un gouvernement
d'austérité c'est vrai que Manuel Lopez
au Bras d'Or vous l'avez dit et de
gauche en tout cas c'est là qu'on le
situe sur l'échiquier politique
mexicain la dépendance du Mexique
vis-à-vis des États-Unis alors le
Mexique c'est une date importante dans
l'histoire récente de ce pays en 94 à
signer le fameux le fameux Alena cet
accord de libre-échange entre les
États-Unis le Canada et le Mexique mais
c'est une conséquence assez forte ça
pour le Mexique c'est qu'il est obligé
de basculer si on peut dire les choses
comme ça dans le libéralisme ou jusque
là c'était un pays relativement
protectionniste mais avec cet accord
c'est plutôt les règles libérales qui se
sont imposées au pays est-ce que on
n'explique pas aussi par là les
inégalités dont on parlait à l'instant
j'aurais tendance effectivement à penser
c'est le constat qui est fait
généralement de la même manière qu'on
constate un échec contre la drogue je
pense qu'il y a il y a un échec
effectivement ce qui a été enclenché
avec la l'accord de libre-échange avec
du Nord donc il y a lié à le Mexique les
États-Unis et le Canada à partir de 1994
qui devait être bénéficiaire pour tout
le monde c'était l'ouverture sur le
monde l'ouverture à ce grand marché qui
est le plus grand commercial existant au
monde c'est une bonne chose pour le pays
je pense qu'on peut objectivement dire
que non de
la vie générale effectivement quel qu'il
soit et quel que soit la couleur
politique et même l'ancien partisan de
cet accord sont revenus là-dessus ça n'a
pas bénéficié au Mexique qui a été
arrimé à l'économie américaine qui a
perdu effectivement une grande partie de
l'autonomie qu'il avait
notamment dans le domaine énergétique où
pendant des domaines sources
stratégiques
qui est dépendant ne fait plus ses choix
en faisant au passage un aspirateur de
migration vers le nord du pays où on a
parlé des makiladoras ces usines dans
dans lesquelles travaillent notamment
des femmes et dans des situations
extrêmement difficiles donc c'est très
très dur oui je pense qu'objectivement
et vous dites oui oui deux fois oui vous
aussi ça a été un échec moi je vais vous
parler plutôt du côté culturel qui est
ma spécialité mais par exemple le
Mexique était un grand pé de cinéma un
grand pays producteur de cinéma qui
continue à l'être mais à partir de la
signature de l'ALENA mais il avait plus
de place dans ses propres salles de
cinéma pour diffuser ces productions
très riches primées si je vous dis
Alfonso quaron comme ça les signarrit
tout ce sont des réalisateurs de premier
plan qui sont mexicains mais du coup
avec cet accord et bien il n'y a plus de
de possibilité de quota pour les films
mexicains comme ce qu'on a en France
donc on se le Mexique se retrouve inondé
de production et pas toujours les plus
belles
d'Hollywood et du coup avec un vrai
sacrifice de son secteur culturel et
lorsqu'ils ont souhaité mettre en oeuvre
justement une politique similaire à
celle de la France
ou une partie du prix du billet de
cinéma va à des financements ça a été
opposé par les États-Unis les Médor
américaines les grandes
chaînes de production américaine et
compagnie twenty US Century Fox etc on
portait plainte
dans le cadre de l'ALENA en disant ben
voilà et on ne respecte pas la libre
concurrence donc cette loi a dû être
abrogée
depuis 2018 mais c'est le c'est le même
principe c'est un système et un marché
ouvert entre Canada Etats-Unis et
Mexique vous voyez d'autres peut-être
illustrations mettent en ont en avant
pour illustrer cette dépendance du du
Mexique aujourd'hui
vis-à-vis des États-Unis il explore par
exemple ce pays dixième producteur de
pétrole au monde et l'exporte quasiment
toute sa production aux États-Unis bon
il y a comme ça d'autres exemples
peut-être qui vous viennent en tête pour
illustrer cette dépendance vis-à-vis des
États-Unis c'est le secteur énergétique
c'est le secteur agricole il y a plus de
choix effectivement dans la dans la
production comme toujours et on peut
revenir à ça c'est l'économie la plus
formelle c'est aussi l'économie
informelle cette dépendance économique
est aussi celle du trafic de les deux
sont d'ailleurs très imbriqués
c'est que presque
deux mexicains sur trois seraient dans
cette fameuse économie à formelle dont
vous parlez là et on sait que c'est lié
le la production d'avocats ou de citron
par exemple et maintenant un très
intimement lié au trafic de drogue de
même que certaines exploitations
minières et aussi dans le reste du pays
l'exploitation pétrolière c'est devenu
un tout effectivement ce tout d'une
dépendance
des ressources vers le nord il est
certain que le Mexique n'a pas bénéficié
pourtant le Mexique c'est une très
vieille civilisation et civilisation ou
pluriel le la première trace humaine
retrouvée au Mexique c'est 30000 ans
avant notre ère avant Jésus-Christ
est-ce que la cohabitation entre
l'histoire de ce pays et le Mexique
d'aujourd'hui se fait correctement ou
est-ce que la mémoire
civilisatrice de ce pays est en train de
se elle aussi de se dissoudre
je vais revenir à cette Alena en 94
juste avant la signature en fait pour
convaincre les législateurs américains
du bien fondé de cet accord avec avec
les Mexicains et les Canadiens une
grande exposition culturelle est
organisée aux États-Unis qui est
inauguré par le prix Nobel de
littérature Octave et qui s'appelle
Mexique 36 siècles de splendeur je pense
que ça résume bien c'est une culture
extrêmement riche qui à la différence
d'autres pays de d'Amérique latine a su
garder la richesse de sa culture
autochtone très vivante
ce sont 62 langues différentes au
Mexique bien sûr le Musée National
d'Anthropologie fait beaucoup plus la
part belle aux cultures pré-ispaniques
mais on garde quand même
une importance beaucoup de programmes
publics de soutien de valorisation de
ces cultures
mais aussi de ces cultures
urbaines qui sont très bien montrées je
trouve dans le documentaire avec ces
photos des solos qui me rappellent aussi
une une super production qui a eu lieu
récemment il y a quelques années en 2020
je crois qui montre là aussi un autre
lien avec le documentaire sur la région
de Monterey qu'on a l'habitude de
comparer à une espèce d'annexe des
États-Unis très très riches comme on
voit dans dans le documentaire avec
Yvonne Vignier il y a mais là c'est une
communauté de il s'appelle les
colombianos et c'est un film qui
s'appelle je ne suis plus ici et qui
montre bah c'est ces jeunes qui ont une
sous-culture
urbaine mais avec un mélange de de
culture populaire colombienne justement
et puis on voit un récit d'immigration
aux États-Unis
les difficultés de cette immigration
sans papier sans qualification et puis
au final le retour le retour au Mexique
le retour aux racines avec une phrase de
l'acteur pour dire non je ne repartirai
plus là-bas restons sur une autre
positive pour finir d'autres atouts du
Mexique le tourisme par exemple c'est
c'est
un domaine très important qui rapporte
aussi pas mal d'argent à ce pays on a
envie d'aller au Mexique lorsqu'on
habite le continent américain évidemment
il faut parler il faut faire le pont le
tourisme par le pont avec la culture je
plus soit notamment sur cette référence
et que je ne suis plus ici
avec une culture urbaine qui au passage
fait référence aussi en culture
précolombiennes dans les coupes de
cheveux qui va chercher il y a une
richesse culturelle extraordinaire
alors l'historien va parler le il y a
une qualité de réflexion sur ce qui a
été la conquête sur ses conséquences sur
le rapport effectivement aux cultures
autochtones préconquête sur ce qui a été
la colonisation est-ce que c'est qu'une
réflexion de coloniser de
post-colonialiste il y a une richesse
dans la dans la réflexion dans le
travail intellectuel et dans la culture
et la promotion culturelle pour tout ce
qui est extraordinaire et qui est
absolument appréciable et le tourisme au
passage est une belle opportunité de
découvrir toute cette richesse vous
voulez ajouter quelque chose oui je sais
pas si j'aurais gardé le tourisme comme
la chose la plus positive
malheureusement je pensais récemment
très important pour ce pays mais qui a
qui peut aussi être dévoyé il y a une
enquête récente de Libé sur le surf et
quand une plage mexicaine a été
découverte par des grandes marques et
compétitions de surf et bien on retrouve
les mêmes thématiques qu'on retrouve
auprès de l'avocat la main Miss du
narcotrafic encore une fois dessus mais
ce qui n'empêche pas de visiter le
Mexique il y a un pays absolument
fabuleux on finira sur sur ces paroles
merci vraiment à tous les deux d'être
venu sur ce plateau de débat doc après
ce documentaire le Mexique dans
l'objectif que nous avons vu à
l'occasion de cette émission merci à
tous les deux d'avoir parlé de ce pays
peut-être d'avoir donné envie à certains
de s'y rendre et de se rendre compte sur
place de la richesse évoquée à l'instant
culturel de ce pays malgré malgré la
très forte criminalité et les très forts
inégalités qui caractérisent
malheureusement aussi aujourd'hui le
Mexique pour réaction ça sera sur
hashtag débadoc sur Twitter bien entendu
merci à celle massalik et dites cette
émission et qui m'a comme à l'accoutumée
aidé à la préparer je vous donne
rendez-vous tout simplement pour un
prochain débat doc et ça sera bien sûr
avec son documentaire et son débat très
bientôt
[Musique]